punjab es la primera provincia
productora de leche en pakistán el 80%
de la producción lechera está en manos
de pequeños negocios familiares como el
de mohamad nader junto con sus hermanos
dirige esta granja lechera en la familia
desde hace tres generaciones posee
alrededor de 50 vacas y búfalas que le
dan unos 1000 litros de leche al día es
una búfala de agua su leche se vende a
150 rupias en litro la calidad de su
leche es muy superior a la de una vaca
su leche es más espesa y está llena de
nutrientes una vez que uno empieza a
tomar leche de búfala ya no regresará a
la leche de vaca desde hace unos años
este granjero ha tenido dificultades
para ganarse la vida la crisis económica
en pakistán acentuada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 disparó los costos de producción
para aumentar sus ventas no jamás nadie
le añade esta agua del grifo a su leche
no obstante ignora la calidad del agua
conocida por estar contaminada
así es como diluimos la leche con agua
añadir el litro de agua a 30 litros de
leche de esta manera puedo ganar 50
rupias más por litro antes de 2015
ciudadano de las bestias y de la granja
nos costaba menos podíamos ahorrar mucho
dinero gracias a esta granja lechera
pero ahora los gastos prácticamente se
han duplicado pasamos de 80.000 rupias a
150 mil la inflación en el país ha
aumentado así que la única manera que
tenemos para obtener ganancias es
añadirle agua a la leche mohammad le
distribuye leche a los comerciantes y
también se le entrega directamente a los
habitantes de su pueblo en las tiendas
el litro de leche envasada cuesta 165
rupias unos 95 céntimos de dólar este
hombre no tiene los medios para
comprarla así que todos los días recibe
un litro de leche de moja más nada y
pagó 130 rupias por un litro sé que
mezclan la leche de vaca con leche de
búfala no le ponen nada más antes
comprábamos la leche en una granja que
estaba en nuestra calle
porque nos dimos cuenta de que le
agregaba mucha agua el granjero no
corrige lo que dicen sus clientes sobre
la composición de la leche que le vende
el 70 por ciento de la leche a granel en
punjab contiene restos de productos
químicos y bacterias nocivas para
ponerle fin a la catástrofe la autoridad
alimentaria provincial organiza
controles relámpagos en la vía a la
entrada de la ciudad el contenido de los
contenedores de leche pasa por un
proceso de cribado
debe una muestra de ese recipiente uno
de ustedes debe venir conmigo debemos
anotar sus coordenadas para realizar la
trazabilidad de la leche
13 militares del equipo tal señora aquí
está la muestra
las muestras de leche se analizan en
estos laboratorios móviles se obtienen
resultados en 15 minutos
así me hable que quien transporta esta
leche su leche es de baja calidad
contiene 25 por ciento de agua su valor
nutricional es bajo y la cantidad de
materia grasa también esta vez los
dejaremos ir sólo con una multa ni a
todos les conviene ahora esas extracción
de nadie
el nombre deberá pagar tres mil rupias
de multa unos 17 dólares ahora su nombre
figure en una base de datos de la
autoridad alimentaria de punjab adela
slam es el director de las operaciones
del organismo gubernamental han
controlado 11 mil litros de leche y hay
un total de 27 mil rupias en multas unas
personas me entran intencionalmente
fertilizantes detergentes en polvo
productos químicos o leche en polvo
nosotros hacemos un control masivo
llevamos a cabo redadas abrimos procesos
penales en su contra la policía de
detención una vez los culpables de
dispararon a nuestro equipo por fortuna
a nuestros hombres sobrevivieron pero
fueron gravemente heridos
a lo largo de los últimos años se han
llevado a cabo varias incautaciones de
leche fabricada a partir de jabón o
fertilizante el impacto sobre la salud
que tiene el consumo de esta leche
adulterada de mala calidad es desastroso
según afirman los médicos
es hospital recibe cada semana pacientes
cuyos síntomas no dejan lugar a dudas
sobre su causa cómo se siente un poco
mejor es que cuanto más tierna tengo
diarrea que leche consume la leche
envasada o la leche cruda del lechero y
compre la leche al lechero de la esquina
ya había notado que estaba mezclada con
algo si a veces cuando calienta la leche
queda un recibo blanco en el fondo en la
olla pienso que está mezclado con algo
porque sigue comprando porque podemos
pagar
en el caso de la mayoría de los
pacientes que vienen la consulta por una
diarrea crónica una gastritis o incluso
un cáncer de estómago al observar su
historial médico vemos que consumen
leche no pasteurizada y a granel
el 90 por ciento de los paquistaníes
consumen leche cruda vendida a granel
porque no está gravada con impuestos a
diferencia de la leche envasada vendida
en las tiendas